yeah so this game was played in 2015
in being the game dingley rin
um this was played 2015. so dingle iron
was already clearly a very strong player
his rating at the time
of the game was 2781 so
clearly tough five level strength
and uh yeah five years ago
and it's also the last game that
dingleran played the
king's indian defense basically because
if you remember
if you look back five or seven years ago
being lyran used to play
nothing but the king's indian defense
with black
so now he plays queen's gambit semi-slav
but back in those days he plays nothing
but king's indian all his life
so king xinjiang i don't think many
people remember
the fact that ding used to play
exclusively the king's indian defense
in a high level nowadays not many people
to
play the king's engine but
yeah he played d6 he was clearly well
prepared
and let's just go quickly this is the
main line
of uh the classical kings indian defense
where white plays very logically
developing bishop on e2 knight on f3 and
shorts castle so it's
the classical way of playing against the
king's engine and not to play for any
tricks
or or anything like that in the opening
but just develop your pieces and castle
and um thrust on this
on the strength of your center pawns so
knight c6 also the most ambitious move
for black
d5 97 and
here my favorite move back then and
still is is knight e1
and this is the classical main line
because here white has many moves
there's the bionic attack a very
fashionable move
i guess there's also knight d2
amongst other things boris girl fan
played the very interesting
bishop g5 i believe provoking h6
and then if you play h6 then he retreats
to d2
if i remember correctly and now this
pawn on h6 can be a target later on
so there are many lines but i like
knight e1 and what knight e1 does is two
things
now first black is threatening knight h5
so with knight e1 we prevent knight h5
so that's the first thing the second
thing is it covers the g4 square
so in many lines we're threatening to
advance with g4
and game space the third thing is that
it frees up
the f3 square for the f pawn so
many lines we play f3 to defend the e4
square
and finally the knight is very well
placed after
an eventual knight d3 because on d3 the
knight
attacks the e5 square and the c5 square
protects the f4 square
so 91 is a general all-purpose move
and black has to play knight d7
because if he plays knight e8 then after
bishop e3
the attack on the queen side is very
powerful with c5
it's very fast and and it's all about
mating ideas here
in the black wheel attack on the king
side white will push on the queen side
and try to get rid of this bishop on c8
but uh yeah i played this line a few
times
so let's take a look bishop e3 this is
my
the line that i like playing bishop f2
and g5
so black doesn't
black just wants to give checkmate for
sure
so we have to be careful with our king
and yeah
if you guys have any questions feel free
and here i played this line
many times in my life i played g4
against dingley
ren back in 2011 and i played g4 against
vanwelli also
but those games went well but later
black found the equality against g4
g4 the idea is to close the kingside
but the other line is knight d3
followed by c5 and we go for this queen
side attack
but i decided to play this line rook c1
and the idea is to play c5 also
and the rook is useful on the square but
after knight g6
i played this c5 move right away which
is upon sacrifice
and in this position i could play knight
d3
but then it would slow down my queen
side attack and then black plays
some rook at 7 and then h5 g4
and probably mate could come if white is
not accurate
so i played c5 by the way i played this
already before
uh the idea is it's a pawn sacrifice if
black takes with the pawn
then uh the c file gets quickly opened
after b4 possibly takes
knight b5 and black cannot defend this
pawn on c7
so the position opens up so ding lyran
took the pawn because if he didn't take
them attacks very fast
and now after b4 the point of the pawn
soccer 5 is that
black cannot play knight d7 as after
knight b5
there's no way for him to defend the
pawn he's one one tempo too slow
and so instead knight d7 which is not
playable
black has to retreat to knight a6 and
this has been played
in several games but after
knight d3 uh it turns out that black's
knight on b
on a6 is far away from where it should
be
this knight should be on the king side
say on f6
but on a6 this knight extremely passive
it's not doing anything
okay it defends this square but other
than that
it becomes of a very defensive nature
and let's say black plays h5 with ding
which dingler ended
and the difference now is that without a
knight on f6
when black plays g4 we can actually just
take twice
takes takes and then
black has no attack and and
his bishop on g7 is very poor so
bing finally has had enough and he
played g4 because he can't hang on to
his queen side i'm thirteen knight takes
pawn
and if he plays fairies problems with
knight and if he plays knight b8 they're
still knight takes pawn
and it's game over and in this kind of
pawns
in this kind of king side king's indian
pawn structure the bishop
the life squad bishop is the most
important piece
for black uh in the entire opening
because once you get a position like
this
let's just say this will happen if your
bishop is
on the light square you can always sack
on h3
but without the light squared bishop on
the board you it's like you could almost
never checkmate white
because you have no piece to sacrifice
on h3
so that's why usually in this king's
indian pawn structure
once the light squared bishops are gone
it's basically game over
for black so ding plays g4
time to attack now uh he's taking
advantage of the fact that if i take
twice
this knight on b5 is hanging so that's
the reason why he can play
queen 83 so ding played night before
very nice move because he wants to
sacrifice the knight for an attack
but he doesn't want to do it right away
he wants to grab a pawn
so basically this knight is on a suicide
mission
and he takes a wide pawn with him to the
next life
um i have to take the knight
and f3 ding's very aggressive
calculating player
so he's trying to keep checkmate with a
handful of pieces
for example if i take take then the g
file opens
knight comes here and maybe white will
end up getting mated after all
for example i don't think i can play
knight
d3 here because
if you're h2 working
maybe it's got knight h4
hmm okay should take i don't remember
now but probably black can play
something like knight h4
and if you take queen takes h4 and g3
it's a very dangerous position for white
so i have to look for counter play
because
black is just going to double in the
hvac so queen c4
is a nice move exploiting the weakened
square now queen c6 is a threat
attacking the rook and threatening queen
e8
to trade queens so ding lyran of course
sees it
he plays through very nice move the idea
to defend the
the back rank uh in preparation for
possible queenie
so here i'm threatening to exchange
queens ding plays queen h7
because if he trades queens then it's
game over as he's a piece down
so he's threatening mate i can't play h4
because he'll just sacrifice a piece
if i have to play h3 but this move is
very nice because
whenever black takes then just king h2
and this h pawn is actually
a shield which protects us from mate
along the h file
uh through b8 i was trying to to take
his rook
knight to d1 bring a knight closer to
the defense
on e3 and also exerting extra pressure
on
c7 and here ding made the blunder
but not an obvious blunder at that he
played a6
but the right mode for black was very
hard to see
yeah and this is why it's a blunder
because after a6 bing probably thought i
had to retreat my bishop because it's
attack
but he missed this check
and he probably thought check doesn't
make sense because check
that i move my king and attack your
queen
so queen has to move right but he may
squint the e8
or maybe he didn't miss it he just
underestimated it
so the point is now we have a piece and
so after taking on the
we have two pieces and black took the
queen
and we took the pawn so we have two
pieces for the queen right now
but black uh if in check
and if he moves the king then we can
capture
and we get this position where we have
uh
two pieces in return for this rope
uh our pieces are well coordinated and
in general in the end game white is
always almost always favored in the
king's indian
because he played the king's indian to
mate your opponent
so being played bishop d7 but after
takes
uh and king h2
uh let's uh let's take a look at the
position now my king is very safe i'm
not going to get checkmated
and he has a queen but in return we have
two bishops
two bishops are extremely strong in an
open position
especially with no other no competition
on the board
so in turn for the queen we have two
bishops and a knight
and our minor pieces if they're
coordinated
they're almost they're almost always
stronger than a queen
so three minor pieces if they're
coordinated and protecting each other
and well placed like here my bishop was
outpost here
my knight has an outpost on f5
so three pieces are usually too strong
for the queen if they can coordinate
themselves
which they are working very well right
now
here actually white is just completely
winning uh i didn't
uh find the fastest way to win but what
i played was good enough
so as you can see look at my pieces
they're like extremely well placed
and protected the knights are guarding
each other
the knight is guarding the bishop
there's bishop on f5
and black's king can hardly move this
this lady right here
can barely do anything and here i took
on d7
eliminating his last piece um
it's also good enough for a win takes
rook at 7 and now rook f5
um i guess if we place queen g6
uh what do i have here some bishop
bishop f8 probably
targeting at this pawn on d6
and yeah it should be game
over for night these three pieces are
supporting each other and now f7 and
bishop e7 comes
and yeah
because black is way behind in material
and here f7 bishop e7
this trial here are very nice
protecting everybody and all starting
bishop e7
so think tried one last hail mary play
with e3
but it didn't work because he's just too
slow
and so now whatever black does he's lost
because if he takes on f7 then i capture
the queen
and if he plays e2 with the threat of e1
and it seems like he's gonna win he's
gonna get a new queen
we have this check
black takes a knight it's okay we're
still two pieces up
we have this night this tree zag takes
and we're only a piece up but it's
enough to win
because for example black spawns are too
slow
push king push king
push king takes b3 takes
a3 knight d4 a2
knight c2 and protect
the passer so just in time
that's a nice variation actually um
yeah white is just in time um
yeah i guess knight d4 is long eight x b
or eighteen also wins
so we don't we don't win
just by that move eighteen was also
winning
so bishop p7 ding tried e2
uh but uh i guess bishop takes f8 is
fine
but knight h4 is even stronger because
we force
black to retreat here because if he
takes
then we're captured with check
being played here queen but after bishop
takes d6
this pawn is protected and we're
threatening to promote
and so being gabe checks checks
but after king g4 black has no perpetual
check
because if he checks here then we cover
with knight f3
so black has no perpetual check because
next comes the umbrella bishop f4 and if
you check here
then we can cover this way
well if he checks here we can cover this
way
and finally dingler ener sign because
this pawn is going to promote